are you doing okay man course it's just
last year you weren't all you know great
this time of year what are you talking
about it's the day after Christmas I've
got some leftovers and a bunch of TV to
watch life is good I just I know you
like structure I'm a little sad while
you haven't moved much did you know that
heat is on Netflix now I didn't you know
what that's about yeah I need to change
okay my life I need to fundamentally
alter the course of my life man it feels
like all I ever do is watch Heat been 3
days I'm not accustomed to unstructured
play time don't say it like that I feel
motivated ready to improve my life I'm
going to go to the gym and I'm going to
stop watching heat great but I can't
change myself now not now two days
before New Year's it's a bad time to
turn your life around no it's a great
time you've got time off you know what
I'm just going to soak up the misery Go
full despair you know get it all out of
my system you're going to rewatch I'm
going to rewat heat finally New Year's
Eve I'm excited to be done with this
depressing phase of my life tomorrow
you're going to make a change and and be
the man you always wanted to be right uh
yeah well no I wish I had time but back
to work tomorrow you know at least I had
a relaxing break though